Hey,
what's going on is bill bar and it's time for the Monday morning podcast from
Monday,
October 5th,
2015 uh,
you're gonna have to deal with this.
This is the level of talking then I'm going to be able to do,
because I have a couple of guests here in my house and it's a 8:00 AM and I'm
trying to be courteous,
unlike the cunt that called me at six 58 in the morning.
I thought it was some fucking radio guy,
you know,
for some Gig I had back east,
I had no idea.
It was like,
I was like,
well,
what?
And he was like,
I guess my wife's schedule some fucking shit here at the house on Sunday.
Saturday.
She wasn't even aware of it.
I don't eat something about the fucking alarm.
He goes,
well,
anyway,
I have to reschedule that.
It's like,
well,
uh,
I dunno about this one.
I got to wait to,
my wife wakes up and he goes,
okay,
something I woke you up too.
It's like,
yeah,
it's six 58 in the morning.
You can't with your fucking morning DJ voice a,
it's any in the bull die.
We got bill coming up.
He had a bed as that.
He's got to be at two showers here in Maryland.
I'm sorry it was a bad morning DJ voice,
but you know something.
I'm trying to be courteous to other people in the fucking house here.
All right,
whatever.
Let's plow through the podcast here.
Uh,
I've got to say something.
I've got to get something right off right off my old freckled fucking chest
here.
Uh,
to start this thing.
All right.
The W hotel,
I am fucking done with that place at a great weekend,
right?
I did a couple of benets benefits out in,
uh,
DC and um,
one of the Tig Notaro set up for planned parenthood and it was such a fucking
cool crowd.
My whole set.
I just kept telling him that they didn't like babies.
One of my favorite things to do when you do a benefit as you go out there and
then you act like you don't understand the point of view of the people that are
doing the benefit,
unless it's something fucking horrific.
You know what I mean?
Like if it's,
you know,
kids with cancer or something like that,
then I behaved myself,
but it's like planned parenthood or uh,
you know,
the right to life.
If it was the right to life people,
I would tease them that they've haven't looked at a census and how many people
are on the planet.
Um,
hey,
let's keep adding more baby.
They'd would just do something like that,
something,
anything to just kind of kill the fuck tensioned of the one subject that you're
not supposed to talk about.
So,
um,
it was just an awesome crowd and I kept going back to that and they had a great
sense of humor about themselves.
They kept laughing when I was saying it.
Um,
you know,
the rest of my act,
it was a little touchy dcs really fucking touchy,
by the way.
If,
if what I found,
if you perform it,
the DC improv though,
it's a great crowd.
You get a couple of uptight people there or whatever.
Like if once you get out of the clubs and he becomes a bigger event,
like that benefit that was at like a theater,
it's just this really weird sort of um,
pay attention to what you laugh at kind of thing.
Like it's,
it feels like a political fundraiser for whatever fucking reason.
But a Friday night they were cool.
And then on Saturday,
um,
did the addiction benefit that a Marianne Geraldo,
Greg draw those wife put together and uh,
Jesus Christ,
what a fucking show that was everybody murderer and Tom Papa putting on a
clinic.
Nick Depaulo,
uh,
Judy gold.
Tig was on that one too.
Gary Owen.
I mean it was just a fucking,
just a monster show.
I know I'm going to forget a few people,
but uh,
everybody was route.
What was really cool was it just a bunch of different styles in everybody with
their own style?
Absolutely.
Fucking destroyed.
And a dude,
I got to tell you something,
Nick Dipaolo,
man,
it's probably the most underrated comedian out there,
man.
If,
if that guy's playing in your area,
you got to go see him.
He's fucking,
if you want to see,
just like completely uncensored somebody just saying exactly what they're
thinking,
ah,
that's the guy to go see.
And uh,
he does not take an ounce of shit from anyone in the crowd now.
Like he should be giving him shit.
But I'm just saying if,
um,
he addresses groaners put it that way,
is the best way to put it.
But,
um,
so it was great working with all those guys and I'm just had,
just had a great fucking nights.
So anyways,
so after the shelf Saturday night,
um,
you know me,
Tom Papa,
and uh,
you know,
Al Madrigal,
we all go out to a,
to dinner or something like that,
right?
And have a couple of drinks and then we head back to the fucking w hotel or me
and Tom did anyways,
because that's where we,
where we were staying to.
And it was just an absolute fucking shit show.
That hotel,
I'm not saying it's a bad hotel,
but that hotel is for young people.
It's not for 47 year old fucking freckled Douche bag like me.
I just couldn't get over the level of shit faced.
This is coming from a drunk,
how fucking hammered these people were.
First of all,
I walked by the w hotel at like,
uh,
what the fuck was I with?
I was with somebody
and how the whole weekend kind of blended together,
but I swear to God it was the afternoon and these fucking,
these three like hot chicks come walking out with,
with tattoos on their titties,
like script writing.
They will horse horse just walking right out.
I'm not saying professional,
but you know,
if that should daughter,
you're just,
you just talking to a wall for the rest of your life being like,
I completely fucked up script writing on your titties that I,
I'm telling you right now,
if you were a man and a woman walks up to with script writing on her fucking
titties,
I'm telling you,
you run in the other direction.
All right.
Nothing good is going to come from that interaction.
Okay.
And if there's any ladies listening out there,
I challenge you to find a wholesome woman who's going to be a good mother.
Was script writing on her teddies all right.
I'm sure you can find one.
Just like I can find a white guy that can dunk a basketball.
There's always fucking exceptions.
All right?
But I'm just saying generally speaking,
not even generally 90% fucking speaking my favorites percentage,
90%.
You just,
you just run in the other fucking direction.
So anyway,
so we come back from the,
uh,
from the fucking dinner and dude,
like this woman was so folk outside,
this woman was so fucking drunk,
like the kind of drunk you get when you're in your 20s,
you don't know how to stop,
right?
Leather Pants,
Dress like,
you know,
she's going to be an a Rianna video.
She's so drunk.
The guy she's with is trying to hold her up and she's got her head buried into
him.
Like she's in like a rugby scrum,
just sorta trying to walk into,
and he's going,
sweetheart,
sweetheart.
And we kind of,
I was like,
Jesus Christ,
what the fuck is all these,
you know,
fucking tattooed titty hose.
A walking out of the w.
What's so funny is when you check in the place during daylight hours,
like it seems like a nice hotel,
but they always had like the fucking club or duck club,
da Apostrophe,
whatever.
The young kids saying,
somebody is up this spinning right when the fucking it,
it turns into an absolute fucking shit show.
And nobody can hold their alcohol or,
or fucking did too many drugs.
I don't want his,
he was his fucking,
this lady is like buried her head into this guy and his legs.
She's trying to like,
uh,
get a first down and we looked away and then all of a sudden you heard,
boom,
the unmistakable sound of a head hitting something solid.
And she had fallen down on her backside and,
and her momentum carried her into the cab,
the side of the cabinet.
She was,
they were trying to stick her into,
and she fucking banged her head.
Um,
and then she got up
and was laughing.
And I w I,
I wanna say it was because she was a dumb cunt.
All right.
Now somebody could say,
well,
why don't you look at it like,
you know,
she's got a sense of humor about herself,
like the right to life people.
You know what,
she was too pretty to have a sense of humor about herself,
you know?
And that's probably my,
you know,
issues with those types of fucking women.
Uh,
which of course most of it is.
But yeah,
I would just say no.
She just was like,
oh,
this is funny.
Cause there's no consequences to anything I did because this is a drunk as I am.
I probably paid for one fucking drink this night.
You know what I mean?
Oh,
this is stupid laptop.
Let me know.
I got to fucking message.
MMM.
So,
uh,
okay.
Yeah,
I think she just was enjoying the attention.
And then her boyfriend finally snapped and was like,
will you shut the fuck up and get in the fucking cab?
And she was still laughing.
You know what I mean?
And I bet when it happens again,
she'll laugh again because no one will ever slap the shit out of her because
she's a woman and it's against the rules.
You know what I mean?
So anyways,
so then me and fucking,
uh,
okay
Tom walk into the,
uh,
not saying that you should slap the shit out of a woman,
but you know,
there is something to be gained every once in a while when you've truly in the
wrong and somebody just slaps you in the fucking face and,
uh,
you know,
all you have to deal with this,
the stinging pain for about eight seconds.
There is kind of a,
uh,
let me,
what do I think about,
uh,
some of my behavior over the last couple of minutes.
Um,
another great advantage to being a guy.
Also,
you can have a beard so you can kind of cushion the sting of the slap is he
advocated domestic.
Um,
so then we go into the,
uh,
the w hotel.
Um,
by the way,
what I just said,
there is most bloggers fucking thought process before they sit down to type.
Um,
anyways,
so we go into the fucking w hotel.
And was that just like weaving our way through unbelievably fucking shit faced
people?
Uh,
there doesn't seem to be any sort of concern as to how these people are getting
home.
If they're driving.
It is a city,
so I guess everybody was sorta cabinet or ubering it.
I don't know what the fuck they were doing.
So weaving our way through these people,
we get to the fucking,
you get to the,
the,
the elevators and they got three elevators.
One of them goes up to the top with a bar is,
it's basically the shit show elevator.
Then the other two is for fucking old people who just want to go to their room
and go to bed.
And of course the shit face.
People keep getting on the wrong elevators and all that type of stuff.
Right.
So as we're standing there,
all of a sudden this sea of fucking guys walked in wearing Tuxedos and for some
reason they have these little stuffed animal ponies with them.
MMM.
And they're just all come filing in to go to bed.
And I'm looking at Tom gone off,
fuck these guys and they're fucking drunk as hell.
And the guy shows up next to me,
goes through you.
Odd By pony is fuck a guy.
Right?
These guys were like over the top gay and they had like these Hitler youth
haircuts.
It was really fucking bizarre.
And they had Tuxedos and these stuffed animal ponies or some shit.
MMM.
I don't know what was going on.
I have no idea what the fuck was going on.
So we skip an elevator,
um,
and then wait for the next one to come.
And by the time the next shows up as another fucking heard of a Hitler youth,
gay guys with ponies trying to get in this as you have scripted titty drunk
girls trying to figure out how to get up to the fucking top of the place so they
can get even more shit faced.
Um,
so anyways,
you get them to finally get on the fucking elevator and um,
you know,
I
fucking on,
I gotta take this,
I got to hit pause here.
Hold on,
hold on,
hold on.
All right,
I'm back.
Sorry about that.
I get some fucking,
uh,
you know,
I had a relative pass away so I got to go to the fucking funeral.
Sucks.
I moved up when everybody moves up,
you know,
somebody in your family,
passes away.
Everybody moves up a spot.
Everybody's sad and then everybody moves up a spot.
You know what I mean?
Who's next?
Right.
Fucking brutal.
Anyways,
so let's get back to the scripted titty horse.
All right.
The scripted TD,
who was all right and where,
where did I leave you guys?
Scripted titty whores.
Gay Hitler,
youth guys with ponies all dressed in Tuxedos.
Like they just gave a piano concert.
Oh.
However the fuck you said.
So I finally get all the way up to my room and then I walk up and of course my
key doesn't fucking work.
Or maybe I have a key from the wrong hotel,
cause I'm always on the fucking road.
I have no idea.
So I got to go back downstairs,
get back on an elevator that's actually empty and they go downstairs,
doors open up more Hitler youth,
gay guys,
more scripted titty whores,
more fucking rugby scrums and uh,
get my key and I get back up there and I was just like,
Eh,
it's just shit shelf.
I'm not saying it's a bad hotel,
you know what I mean?
It's a fucking great hotel if those,
if that's what you're into.
You know what I mean?
Like stay there during the week I think is fine if you're an old man like me,
but on the fucking weekends it is an absolute fucking shit show.
Like it was literally,
it looked like a convention for reality shows,
you know what I mean?
Uh,
stopped writing script on your titties,
you know,
on VH one.
I'm gay,
show Pony,
World War II plants a piano concert.
Oh,
for the,
for the straight guy,
whatever the fuck you want to call it.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
Doug Kahn,
rugby chicks,
whatever the fuck you want to call it,
but it was a tonight.
Now I'm done.
And you always funny it was during the day,
I was already starting to get that feeling like,
you know,
I,
the second year you get into the WWE when they have like that fucking debt,
that option,
we can have like that neon aquarium lighting around your fucking a bed,
you know,
cause young people thinks that,
that,
that like enhances their sexual experience.
What they're really doing is they're trying to cover for the fact that they
don't quite know what the fuck they're doing.
You know what I mean?
Or maybe it's of the drug thing.
I have no idea.
But I remember that when I was younger and I was going to hook up,
it was all about like the lighting and having the right CD.
It was all this extra shit that you needed to cover up for the fact that you
didn't quite know what the fuck you were doing.
At least that was for me,
whenever I'm just a grumpy old man,
don't listen to me.
So anyways,
I fucking,
uh,
so the food sucks at the w and it's fucking like a zillion dollars.
So I'm like,
all right,
I'm going to walk down the street.
Okay.
And I'm going to fucking,
uh,
maybe find something.
So I'm walking down the street,
it's Saturday afternoon and Hello Annie.
Anna Bama is going to play,
uh,
the Georgia bulldogs between the hedges,
right?
Georgia is favored because Alabama lost to ole miss the fucking week before in
Georgia is actually given two points.
And in the back of my head I was like,
if there was ever a fucking gift it would be Alabama getting points.
But,
uh,
fortunately I don't have access to a fucking,
I'm a sports book.
So,
which is good because that saves me a bunch of money.
Cause anytime you sitting there thinking like,
oh my God,
this is a fucking gift,
you end up losing.
So I walked down the street like two blocks,
not even a block and a half.
And I see this problem like art,
I'm gonna go in there and turns out it's this fucking insane cigar bar slash
sports bar.
I pop in there,
right?
This is fucking guy sitting there,
this southern dude with,
with the Georgia bulldog logo on.
And then there's like this old Jewish dude sitting there and old Jewish dudes
are the fucking best man.
They're the fucking best giving ridiculous,
ridiculous fucking life advice at the most easy going pace ever.
Are you married?
Are you in love?
Well,
that's good,
right?
And they just won't,
they'll walk you all the way through fucking life.
They're the best,
right?
So anyways,
um,
so I'm sitting with that dude.
And then there's the other guy,
you know,
and they both got cigars going and a,
I'm thinking like,
wow,
fucking smoke one later tonight.
I'm not gonna smoke during the day,
but I'm going to watch the fucking game.
So they put the game on the crowd's going nuts,
right?
Fucking Georgia bulldogs that jumping up and down Alabama comes out,
they get right in their fucking face.
I'm getting amped up like I'm going to play the game right?
And it's a cigar bar.
So it's a chill fucking vibe.
You can hear the game.
Everything's great all of a sudden,
right?
It literally is the fucking games going to start this tabletop of five or six
people walk in with this fucking smug jackass who just has a fucking opinion on
everything that he thinks is so God damn fascinating,
which is kind of funny to hear me say,
but at least I know I'm a moron.
God knows I got an opinion on everything,
but I know I'm a fucking moron and I also know that when you go into a fucking
cigar bar,
it's an old man vibe.
Okay,
inside old man voices,
right?
This fucking fat con.
I swear to God,
remember that show Jake and the fat man,
he looked like the fat he sits down and proceeds to start speaking as loud as
you could possibly fucking talk without yelling.
And he keeps talking about these.
He tells his fucking story like three times,
but the cigarettes he got in London that for some reason are not legal in the
United States.
He and he kept going like it's London,
but you cannot get them here.
I've tried to order them,
but they are not legal and he would always end it the same way.
They are not legal.
Then he'd go,
why?
I don't know.
Told that story three times.
He only told it twice,
but I want to say it felt like fucking three and a
is,
he's fucking screaming.
I find,
look over at the old Jewish jewel,
Mike,
if you say,
can you believe this guy?
And the old Jewish guy said something like,
you know,
I feel the same way.
Like when you get on a plane and there's a baby crying next to you.
And I laughed.
I go,
yeah,
but this guy should know better.
And then the guy goes,
I,
he goes,
any fucking,
he just got up and left,
you know,
cause he,
what he had on him,
he had this beautiful fucking Cohiba and he knew better.
He's like,
I'm not going to fucking sit here and smoke this unbelievable cigar with this
fat fuck screaming across the God damn room.
Right.
That'd be like if had like a great glass of wine and the whole time you're
drinking it,
there was some guy yelling in your fucking here.
So he gets up and leaves and I sat there and watched the whole first quarter
while simultaneously trying to think of a nice way to asset guide politely to
shut the fuck up.
Could somebody please help me with this social moment because um,
I was literally muttering over in the corner like I be like,
and no matter how much I tried to be nice,
like by the time I got to the end of the sentence,
the rage would come in and I would drop the F.
Dot.
I been,
excuse me,
sorry.
You know,
I'm not trying to be a jerk here,
but uh,
you sort of yelling and you know,
you're in a fucking cigar bar.
I get dumped.
[inaudible] you can't do that.
Can't do that.
Back it up.
I'm sorry.
I'm not trying to inhibit you from having a good time,
but for some fucking reason you don't give a shit that you're doing that to me.
You Fat.
Fuck right.
They did.
I just kept going like that.
Right.
So I never ended up saying anything.
And I finally,
uh,
okay.
I don't know.
I left after the first quarter and I went back to the fucking w hotel.
And,
um,
by the way,
Jesus Christ,
Huh?
Alabama coming back answering the belt.
Absolutely fucking kick the shit.
I,
the only,
the more they could have done was ripped.
The hedge is out of the fucking ground and God knows I was rooting for Georgia.
I don't even,
I don't even hate Alabama.
It's just you have to root against them.
It's so fucking good.
And uh,
you know what?
I forget the guy's name.
Who is that number two,
that running back that Alabama has?
Jesus.
That guy's a fucking beast.
I don't know the names.
I know number seven on Lsu is a monster.
This guy number two,
like they're making these new kinds of fucking running backs.
I don't get it.
They're built like full backs,
but they run as fast as running backs and then they lower the shoulder and they
just absolutely destroy people.
But,
um,
unbelievable.
A college matchups this weekend,
but none of them turned out to be the games like the back and forth that you
thought they were going to be.
Huh.
Fucking Alabama kicks the shit out of Georgia.
And then Florida who was also undefeated but was getting no respect was playing
ole miss in the swamp.
And everybody's thinking,
well Ole miss beat Alabama,
right.
They're going to have their way with Florida and Florida.
Absolutely kick the fucking shit out of him.
I got to see that game too.
I watched the replay last night and um,
and then Notre Dame,
Clemson,
I was rooting for Notre Dame cause I'm going to Notre Dame USC game and I was
obviously hoping that Notre Dame would win so they'd be undefeated in the game
would mean even more when they played USC.
And as far as I can tell they got handled cause I haven't seen that game yet.
Um,
that game was going on while I was doing the,
uh,
the Geraldo addiction benefit and um,
but one of the stage hands had the game going and I just know it was like 14 to
three forever.
They kind of went out early.
But,
um,
the only game that was really fucking close and exciting was probably a game
nobody thought it was going to be,
which was a hio state versus Indiana,
which I ended up turning on towards the ending because Alabama was just,
Georgia just couldn't answer the fucking bell.
Um,
so I ended up putting that thing on and,
um,
what a fucking game that was.
I love our,
Osu kept thinking they put Alabama to bed now put him to sleep.
Like they had that one touchdown pass and the guy does the old slip,
the fucking throat thing.
Like that's it.
Nail in the coffin,
which,
you know,
I felt it was too in Indiana.
Just kept coming back.
I didn't know Indiana was that good.
They were also undefeated.
So,
uh,
when I'm trying to say is that when I wasn't weaving in and out of scripted
titty horses fucking weekend as I watched a lot of God damn football.
I'll talk NFL here in a minute.
Let me,
uh,
let me get back to the,
kind to do a little bit of ad advertising here.
Hmm.
Sorry,
I have to hunt my password and I forget.
Oh Jesus Christ.
You got to put in 50 fucking God damn things now.
And of course it's wrong.
And of course it's fucking wrong,
you know,
it's just my fucking podcast.
Why the fuck I mean my laptop?
Why the hell would I know how to do it?
Come on.
Uh,
Bam.
There we go.
All right,
let's get into the uh,
the reeds.
It's getting to bill burr reading out loud.
Well,
Gee,
oh,
she's all right.
Dollar Shave Club.
Everyone stop shaving with old raises.
It's gross.
Why are you torturing yourself with a gross old blade week after week?
You know why?
Probably because you don't want to shell out $1 million for a pack of new ones.
A dollar shave club.com has revolutionized the way men shave with dollar shave
club.
You can shave with a fresh blade is often as you want because the delivery,
because they deliver a whole sleeve of amazing razors for just a few bucks a
month.
Their razors are so good.
Millions of guys have joined with the,
yeah,
that and the fact that the other ones that completely overpriced,
even the billion dollar razor corporations are freaking out,
but instead of lowering their bloated prices,
what are these cons?
Stone,
they're trying to fool you into milking the same blade for an entire month and
that's groves.
They've prowess.
Price Gouge does for long enough.
Never go back to squeezing weeks and weeks of shaves out of this of disgusting
Rusty Blade,
joined dollar shave club and use a fresh blade whenever you want.
It feels amazing and it's a third of the price.
Your face will thank you.
All right.
Who wants to go to work with razor burn?
Then have that fat guy telling you you've got to work the weekend.
You know what I mean?
I you want to be nice and feel nice and good when that guy slaps you in the
face.
Join the millions of others who's figured out the smarter way to shave.
Joined Dollar Shave club.com by going to dollar shave club.com/burr that's
dollar shave club.com/bar dollar shave club.com/bar all right.
Oh Jesus,
here we go.
Boop,
boop,
me,
undies,
me.
Andy's no more sweaty taint bu dude,
do me undies beyond ease did great.
Don't say they ate.
Sorry.
I had to switch it up.
They make your balls feel like they're on air.
Yeah,
everyone looks but you don't care cause your balls feel great and yet Taney is
dry.
Don't ask me fucking why.
It's beyond ease.
Put 'em on your Rhonda carriage.
Alright me,
Andy's,
we all know how sexy confidence can be.
Hey,
and that confidence comes from being comfortable.
But how great can you feel if your underwear is wrinkling and riding up on your
balls?
They're creeping up years me gets it.
And that's why they've created the world's most comfortable underwear for a
daily dose of confidence.
You wear underwear every day unless you're Matthew mcconaughey or a scripted
teddy who were,
that's three to 65 days a year.
Rain or shine.
You need to be extraordinary with that without an insane price tag.
We undies understands this and that's why they've created the world's most
comfortable underwear.
Luxury for your balls at half the retail price you'd find anywhere else.
When you look good,
you feel great.
It's a cliche because it's true me.
Andy's understands this and that's why they designed underwear.
They makes you look and feel fantastic.
Uh,
modelle me,
Andy's has made from Odell a fabric that's twice as soft as cotton.
There's twice as soft it,
what is it?
Is it from the Madell tree?
There's this manmade stuff.
Who knows?
But who knows how softer cotton is other than men,
you know,
who have cotton up against their balls?
Uh,
that's twice as soft as an whatever you're wearing right now.
And he says tons of colors and styles and the only place to get matching pairs
from men and women,
they even release a new design every month.
Um,
I wear whatever pair that they ever fucking send me and they feel great against
my balls.
No complaints here.
Plus we all know what a,
that paying for shipping sucks.
So Mandy says,
removed from the equation that from the equation,
all our orders in the u s and Canada shipped for free.
You,
me,
undies even go.
It gives you a money back guarantee.
If you don't love your first pair and you get to keep those for free,
you literally have nothing to loose.
All right?
To sweeten the deal,
me undies is offering you 20% off your first order at [inaudible] dot com slash
bar that's a special offer for just my listeners or whatever else these people
advertise.
Make sure you go to [inaudible] Dot Com to get 20% off your first order and so
that they know that we sent you.
All right.
What do we got left here?
We got?
All right,
let's do two.
One,
two.
All right.
Those are the first two.
Let's get back to the fucking podcast here.
NFL football.
Why pop?
Blah,
Podo Boda um,
I actually took an early flight out.
Okay.
So I could get back in time to watch the NFL football,
which I was able to do by the way,
by the way,
when I was on the plane,
I watched a guy in dress socks.
They weren't gold toes,
they were whatever.
I don't know if they were compression socks.
I don't know what they were,
but they were porno socks,
dark colored socks.
And I watched this guy walk into the,
the bathroom on the airplane.
Okay?
In socks.
Okay.
Which in some weird way is actually
okay
as gross.
He's fucking walking in with your bare feet,
you know what I mean?
Cause there's something about socks that they like absorbent to take fucking
urine and fecal matter and have 'em up against your feet for the rest of your
fucking fly.
But
what the full kind of a fucking animal.
Okay.
I shouldn't say the guy like,
dude,
do you realize you just walked into a public bathroom and your socks
are you out of your fucking mind?
Okay.
At the very least these like 20 people's fucking urine in your socks,
up against your fucking skin animals.
And then I'm also thinking like,
you know,
maybe this guy is preparing for when the dollar collapses or whatever and you
just got to start eating squirrels and everything and,
and maybe,
maybe your neighbor.
And as I'm sitting there puking,
you know,
like Henry Hill,
when they dig up fucking Billy batts and I can't handle it,
you know,
and he's just sitting there,
he's ready for you and give a fuck.
He walked into a public bathroom and his fucking stock and feet.
Yeah.
Absolute fucking animal and had this really nice male stewardess on there.
But every time you went to talk to me he put his hand on my shoulder.
Take your hair.
May,
oh Stewart is you're me out.
I can hear your voice.
Stan Lee,
I don't know.
I think his name is Stanley.
It's an old person name.
Um,
I need to make a human connection,
which who likes the more peanut.
Um,
so anyways,
I landed in time.
Uh,
I only missed the first half of the first game and I went in and I watched the
giants versus the bills.
This makes no sense because I am a patriots fan,
but I fucking love the giants.
I love the giants though.
He's got a great fucking defense.
You see that maniac?
They got our defense,
the guys five 10,
10 if guys five,
four,
10.
I'm so impressed.
My voice is cracking guys.
Five foot 10 playing on the defensive line,
plowed through two guys that got to fucking sack guys a fucking animal.
You Literally Watch.
And Rudy,
you know what's funny,
unlike the movie Rudy,
where the dude playing them look like an absolute pussy who shouldn't even be
playing fucking volleyball.
This guy looked like a fucking animal.
It's like he was five,
10 but it was built like he was fucking six for um,
you know,
they got Odell backup.
You see that catch the guy made it didn't even count was so fucking
unbelievable.
It's still made the highlight reel.
And um,
I dunno,
I was watching what rex could do against a team like that.
Plus,
you know,
rex in our division and a,
I know that we're going to be playing the giants.
I don't know how the fuck we're ever going to beat him.
We never beat them.
They beat us an exhibition.
They beat us in the playoffs to beat us in the regular season.
I don't think we've ever beat the giants during the Tom Kauflin,
Eli Manning,
um,
error.
I wonder when the last time we beat we beat them ones.
I'm sure some fucking nerve to go out there and let me know or tell me that I'm
wrong.
Oh,
Julian fluky booboo or any significant game,
they always kick our fucking ass.
So,
um,
but I always loved defensive minded teams.
Um,
so even though they beat us,
I mean,
what am I going to get mad?
Cause they always beat us.
That's on us,
right.
Figure out how to fucking beat him.
So anyways,
so,
and I also love watching rex loose.
It's fun,
you know,
and uh,
if I could watch him lose while he wears a pink hat and headsets,
I mean,
that's even better.
So,
uh,
I watched that,
still buffalo looked pretty good man and I think they're a,
their quarterback there.
What is it?
Travis Trent,
the black version of that name.
Uh,
I dunno if
Trayvon third guild,
I don't know what his fucking name is.
Dale three.
Um,
he looked fucking great,
you know,
great.
But he looked way better than when we were playing him.
When he was throwing like 90 miles over.
Everybody's head looked like he settled down and everything.
So I got to watch the bills lose and then I watched the packers.
I'm actually play a surprisingly tough game against the 40 niners.
I thought that they were going to crush them,
but as much as the score looked like it was a,
a one sided affair lists and meek using all the sports cliches.
Um,
I thought 49 is played really tough.
And uh,
and then I watched the fucking saints game,
a cowboys game and I had that game fucking recording.
What a God damn game.
Why should all the way to the end and the one time I don't add the extension
right as they're lining up to take the field goal to tie it up.
Um,
my fucking,
uh,
my,
my recorder cut out.
So then I had to go on TV and I was just sitting there,
right?
It's a 30 yard.
Even though they hit the fucking thing and it turns out they missed it and
evidently they missed it.
Cause some guy with a giant white belly,
what I look like a few months ago,
lifted his shirt up and fucking distracted it.
Uh,
let's see.
It's still ended up winning the fucking game.
But um,
I don't know.
You ain't just realize,
I don't know anybody's name.
I could sit there and I can watch the whole fucking game.
I don't know anybody's game.
Who's the cowboys back up?
He's one of those unfortunate guys who's a quarterback,
you know,
who does not look good?
When are you wearing it?
When he was wearing a helmet,
he's got those baby fat cheeks,
you know,
so it all moshes in together.
It looks like Stan Humphreys.
You know what I mean?
That's just so unfortunate because you know,
if you're going to stand back there and have six foot,
four,
six foot,
five inch guys who run full 40 is coming into fucking layout,
you can at least be getting a ridiculous amount of ass.
Right.
You know what I mean?
You could have,
you know,
you could have a cute little face like a old Tony Romo there.
You know,
as he's sitting there wearing the Tom Landry hat,
he's got his arm in a sling.
That's all women give a shit about Dallas.
Oh,
I just want to rub his shoulder.
What did hey break.
Um,
well there his collar collarbone,
white gold.
Um,
anyways,
whatever that guy's name is.
I thought when the saints went ahead head it,
I was like,
God,
they don't have it in him.
This guy's a game manager.
They don't have it in them to come back and score.
And Lo and behold,
they went right down the fucking field and they scored.
And it was great to see Tony Romo really being happy for his backup bite.
He knows,
he knows.
He still has the job.
He knows he's better.
He knows he looks better and a fucking helmet is going to sell more march.
Right.
I don't think I would look any worse in a football helmet and a closeup on HDTV
than that poor son of a bitch that's playing for the cowboys.
But God dammit,
he got the job done,
drove them right down the fucking field,
right through to that tight end that's been there forever.
Jj Witten,
Jj stokes,
whatever the fuck his name is.
I don't know anybody's name anymore.
I don't play fantasy football.
All right.
I'm a man.
I'm over 40.
I'm actually thinking about starting to play fantasy football just so I can
fucking learn the players names again.
I actually am embarrassed to say that I went on the,
uh,
on the Internet to see,
you know,
look at some of the stats of like the top receivers and I didn't know anybody's
name.
I didn't know anybody's name as far as running backs went.
I know Marshawn Lynch,
I know ray rice
and I think it,
I don't know anybody else.
I kept hearing names from the sec going,
didn't that guy play for Arkansas?
Didn't that guy win the Heisman trophy?
Darren McFadden.
Anyone the Heisman trophy in 2009,
I think he was on the saints.
And then the fucking,
uh,
the guy from Arkansas was on,
the cowboys.
I don't know.
I don't know fucking anything anymore.
I don't know what happened to me.
I don't what happened my fucking life,
man.
I used to know all of this,
you know,
I used to collect football cards.
That's what,
that's what it was.
That's what it would.
Um,
anyways,
but it was a great whole fucking,
uh,
great,
weekend and watching football.
And then as always,
I tell you what I do is I take a one o'clock game and I taped an extra one
o'clock and an extra four o'clock game and I also still have the,
the Notre Dame game to watch.
So tonight is Monday night football.
I can watch that Tuesday night.
I can watch the one on one o'clock game.
I don't give a fuck that.
I know what happens.
It's still fun to watch.
Wednesday,
Wednesday I go watch the four o'clock game.
Thursday you got Thursday football Friday or watched the noted game Dame game
and then Saturday it starts all over again.
There you go.
And if you want the woman in your life or the man in your life,
whatever your deal is to feel underappreciated,
you will record football games the way I do.
Then you sit there the whole fucking week.
Watch like you some coach watching game tape.
I gotta.
I got to learn the names.
Guys,
I apologize.
I apologize to anybody who had a great fucking game.
I should at least know you.
God damn name right.
Drew Brees.
I know Aaron Rodgers.
I can't even remember the name of the fucking quarterback from Seattle.
Yeah,
or the quarterback.
What the fuck's it?
Richard Sherman.
Collin Kaepernick.
Who's the guy who's trying to be like the Walton's with 52 kids there for,
for uh,
San Diego.
Philip Morris.
I know him.
Andrew Luck,
I guess quarterbacks you know or I know.
I don't know.
Fuck.
Why the fuck I know there's some guy in Atlanta who is unbelievable.
Unbelievable receiver.
Oh,
Dell.
Becca,
my.
Now.
Bill,
why don't you learn the fucking names instead of torture?
No,
it's all right.
All right.
Sorry.
My mistake.
Oh,
hey,
listen,
I got to give a,
uh,
I gotta give a
shout out here to,
uh,
when I,
when I was in DC,
now that I shit all over the w hotel,
which is a great hotel.
If you're in your twenties,
okay?
And you got scripted titties,
or you're a gay guy with the Hitler youth fucking haircut and a little show
pony.
You know what I mean?
You know,
you're some fucking a hottie with leather pants who's into rugby when you're
drunk.
Um,
I gotta give a shout out here.
Uh,
one of the great things that I've,
I found when I was in DC,
this is for everybody out
there.
Anybody who plays professionally or,
uh,
just as like a drum nerd like me,
I found a great place for 15 bucks an hour that you can go play drums at a,
it's called seven lessons drums in,
um,
in Washington DC.
I showed up there,
um,
I played for two hours on Friday and two hours on Saturday.
I could not have had a better time.
I went to two different drum rooms to drums with top notch.
They were tuned up.
They sounded great.
And um,
I mean that's to me,
if when I'm on the road,
you know,
and uh,
that's one of the greatest days of my life.
If I can be on the road and I can just for two hours during the day,
you know,
to combat the fucking loneliness and all the bullshit that goes on when you're
out there just sitting there,
you know,
sitting there on a Thursday when there's nothing on TV,
do it.
An Espn at two o'clock in the fucking afternoon is one of the funniest things
you're ever going to watch.
Like,
did you see that form a jet making fun of Tom Brady?
It was hilarious.
He gave it up.
He said he's arguably the greatest quarterback of all time,
but he's a nerd.
What do you keep crying?
Kept saying corny.
You guys caught it.
How many air of high fives is this guy get a miss?
Just trashing him of his who's fucking hilarious?
I would think of Tom Brady heard it.
He would laugh and then they went back to skip Bayless and you would have
thought somebody spit on the fucking,
uh,
world trade memorial.
He's like,
his comments were despicable.
I would guess that they're possibly born in jealousy.
His people know I am a huge fan of Tom Brady.
I don't,
I don't agree with those comments.
It's just like,
dude,
are you fucking serious right now?
They want it.
Is,
is,
it's two in the afternoon.
They've already shown you the highlights.
Nothing new has happened and they just got to try and milk it for all its worth.
So there's nothing worth to do.
Um,
people,
uh,
you know,
if you're a fan of this podcast,
if you go to my website and you see the city set,
I'm going to be in.
If you guys know cool studio places where I could just sit down and chill out
and fucking play drums for a couple hours,
uh,
by all means,
let me know.
If you run one,
I'll give it a shout out on the podcast.
It is it,
it's my favorite thing to do when I go on the road.
If I can actually find a place like that.
And I found a great one.
I know there's a lot of comics out there that play drums.
You know,
you bring your iPhone and you plug it in.
You pretend you're fucking John Bonham for two hours.
How much fun is that?
A seven lessons.
Drums in a Washington DC.
If you guys know some other places,
give me the heads up because,
um,
I gotta be honest with you.
It's frustrating,
you know,
to learn some shit and then go on the road for a week and you come back and you
fucking,
you know,
one step forward,
two steps back.
It's a great fucking way.
I feel like I got four hours better or at least maintained it.
So,
uh,
thank you to everybody over there.
Seven lessons trumps all right.
Before I get into the questions,
unfortunately guys got to listen to me read out loud against here for a couple
of a couple more.
Me undies.
We did that one.
Okay.
All right.
Legal Zoom,
everybody.
You know what,
you shouldn't have to choose a random lawyer who charges expensive hourly rates
when you need legal help.
But the legal system is so complicated.
What other choice do you have when you need help with your business or want to
protect your family?
Well,
start with legal zoom.
They make it easy.
They make a nice shade ego game for more than a decade.
They provided a way for regular people,
regular people like you and make,
you know what I mean?
Who were raised right,
who don't have people draw on our Teddy's like you and me to confidently
navigate the legal system.
Legalisms not a law firm.
And that's how they provide such great value.
They don't even rely on charging you by the hour.
Instead,
you'll get transparent pricing and customer reviews so you know exactly what
you're getting upfront.
If you need help with incorporations LLCs,
trademarks,
last wills,
living trusts,
and more legal zooms to smart choice,
this much choice over there.
Uh,
they've got the right people on hand to answer your questions.
And if you need legal advice,
then network of independent attorneys can provide the straight forward guidance
you need.
In most states.
Don't let legal hurdles,
hurdles become an excuse.
Go to legalzoom.com today to start building your own future.
The right way to save even more and a burn the referral box at checkout.
That's legalzoom.com Promo Code Burr.
All right,
a stamps.com or old friends,
stamps.com there's gotta be a better way to,
uh,
to mail and ship stuff.
Going to the post office takes up too much time.
Leasing a postage meter is way too expensive.
Turns out there is a better way.
What is it?
Well,
it's stamps.com stamps.com you can buy and print official us postage for any
letter and package it right from your desk using your own computer and printer
even great gets special postage discount.
She can't find it.
The post office plus stamps.com is the most powerful,
is more powerful than a postage meter at just a fraction of the cost.
You can save at least 50% compared to a postage meter and you'll avoid those
time consuming trips to the post office.
I use stamps.com to send out all my posters,
whatever march Trump's selling.
Uh,
speaking of which I'll be bringing DVDs,
but the last batch of DVDs that I have,
I'm bringing those out on the road and they're all going to be autographed cause
I'm getting them out of the garage cause I'm turning my garage into my little a
Ninja Warrior Gym.
I got my atomic holds.
Ah,
I can't wait anyways.
Um,
plus stamps.com is more powerful than the postage,
than a post speed or at just a fraction of the cost.
You can save at least 50% compared to a postage meter and you avoid all the time
consuming trips to the post.
[inaudible]
I already have.
I already read that right now.
Sign up for stamps.com and use my last name,
birth for this special offer.
A four week trial plus $110 bonus offer that includes postage and a digital
scale.
Don't wait.
Go to.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburrthatstamps.com and
tipper,
uh,
that is correct.
I got my atomic holds and,
um,
I got a buddy coming in who's going to do everything the right way because,
uh,
even though I have a stud finder and I got a drill,
I do not trust myself to put as a standup comic to put this thing up correctly
and not,
uh,
do unbelievable damage to myself,
you know,
and I don't,
we'll be hanging by all my bodyweight,
swinging from one hold to another,
you know,
my pasty legs are out in front of me and then that thing fucking gives way,
I'm at that fucking age for that.
Then I'll have that pain for the rest of my fucking life.
I'll finally know what it's like to be sacked in the NFL,
to fucking be horizontal four feet off the ground and land land on concrete
right there.
Like,
that's what astroturf feels like.
All right,
let's get to the questions.
Um,
by the way,
if you want to,
uh,
you know what,
I don't even have the email.
What is the fucking email?
God dammit.
Bill at the MLM,
podcast.com.
That's where you send all your emails too.
Um,
and if you guys know what better way to fucking learn the players names nowadays
other than playing that fantasy stuff,
I guess I just have to keep going to the website.
Um,
all right.
Boston.
Hey Bill,
me and my wife are headed to Boston for the first time.
Any tips on the best places to eat?
I hate when people do this to me because I moved away from there in 1995.
So half the shit I'm going to tell you to go to,
it's probably not even there anymore.
Uh,
how about things we shouldn't miss?
I'm going to Fenway for sure,
but after that we are clueless.
Any help would be appreciated.
Thanks and love the podcasts except for the disparaging remarks about
Sacramento.
Have fucking ha,
come on dude.
You know,
Sacramento,
Sacramento is a weird place.
You know what I mean?
It's either totally shady or you feel like you're in a Donny Osmond fucking
Christmas special.
That'd be honest with you.
I don't know much about Sacramento to be totally honest with you,
cause every time I stayed there,
I didn't have a car and I was working the,
uh,
the punchline there and I stayed at the comedy condo across the street and then
they had a dirty Mcdonald's that I would go to.
Um,
so that's what it's based on.
Other than the fact,
one time I went to a Sacramento Kings game and I went to the downtown area and I
felt like I was in Utah in the widest Mormon sense of the word.
Um,
she doesn't mean it's bad.
I mean,
I'm white.
I don't know when it's so white that I'm uncomfortable though.
You know what I mean?
I Dunno.
I probably don't know shit.
I will tell you this,
if I've been telling you that I've been watching the ultimate fighter with Conor
Mcgregor,
Conor Mcgregor,
and uh,
and um,
ah,
fuck,
what an asshole.
I was just going to give him props.
A how fucking funny he's bent.
Uriah Jesus Christ.
I got to stop talking on cell phones.
Do that guy.
He's been fucking,
I knew Conor McGregor was going to be funny.
That's why I was tuning in to watch.
But who knew how,
how fucking funny Uriah was having,
I already talked about this.
Well,
Mcgregor was talking shit to him about what the fuck he would do to him and then
he just looks at him.
He goes,
he goes,
Connor,
to do I strike you as a fearful man.
And he keeps making fun of Connor's big fucking head,
which I don't even think he has a big head,
but I think it's starting to fuck with the,
um,
anyways,
it's funny man.
You know what's a great God damn show?
And it's fun watching two guys to talk and Shit,
knowing that neither one of them is full of Shit,
knowing that both of them know how to fight.
You know what I mean?
So many times when you sit there,
you watch your guys talking,
Shit,
I'll fucking do this.
I'll do this.
Yeah,
you don't want to fuck with me.
It's usually people bluffing like me,
you know what I mean?
Oh my good friend Joe to Rosa.
I had never seen a guy who knew how to fight less,
talk more shit and bars,
but he just did it with supreme confidence as he was backing up and the person
would never take in that information.
He'd always kind of psych them out.
Joe's got this way of scrunching up his fucking eyebrows and making this face,
even though he,
he,
he's got glasses on,
you know,
and he looks like he works at a library is you can think,
well maybe this guy knows some shit.
Maybe this guy's fucking crazy.
So anyway,
so it's great to watch them talking shit.
Um,
just professional fighters anyways.
It's not even like they're not talking shit.
They're not talking shit.
They can do everything that they're saying.
Um,
anyways,
sweetener.
That was the next day.
UFC think I got,
I'm,
I'm a,
I'm Jonesing for one.
I think I missed the last one cause I was on the road.
So,
uh,
all right,
whenever I'm babbling here,
let's get to the questions.
All right.
This guy's asking me what's a good thing to do here in Boston?
Uh,
well it's the ice.
A lot to go into Dominic's to get a slice of pizza at that does not exist
anymore.
Um,
you know what's there now?
A W hotel.
I was tell you what it si scripted.
Teddy's go to a,
the w hotel raw right there on fucking warranted street on the corner warrants
history used to be a parking lot.
Do I even know anything anymore?
Combat Zone is all fucking hotels.
I just know touristy shit.
Oh my God,
this is terrible.
The swan boats,
I don't know anything about my city anymore.
Okay.
I know that if you go to Fenway,
they bought up like the surrounding block and he can't go down there.
Do you know what sir?
You've stumped me.
I say go to Harvard Square and go to the tasty.
Get yourself a burger.
That doesn't exist anymore.
Okay?
Oh my God.
This is,
see,
this is what's so fucking sad,
man.
This is what said,
this is why they say you can never go home again because you move away and you
come back.
Everybody moved away or fucking died and everything closed up and is now a
fucking Arby's.
Um,
you know what,
sorry,
you stumped me.
I have no fucking idea.
I have no idea.
Definitely taken a sporting event.
Um,
fortunately with the Internet,
I'm sure you can get some ideas and hey dude,
if you learn anything,
if you go to someplace cool,
why don't you,
why don't you let me know.
Pays a touristy place she can go to is the uh,
the,
the Union Oyster House.
That's like,
you know,
like fucking Paul revere went in there and had a fucking Sam Adams back in the
day.
And by that I mean he had a gay relationship with them cause the beer did not
exist.
Um,
that's a real touristy spot.
I'm sure that's not everybody's rolling their eyes right now.
Like,
oh look,
good dude.
Don't fucking Sandham ne um,
tell you what,
I'll retweet places if people know some good places.
Um,
other than that,
I just know go to the cow loon.
That's why he used to stand up.
They got some good Chinese food.
I got nothing.
I'll go to the new England aquarium.
Go look at the sad fish that want to be back in the ocean.
Oh,
I know the north end.
Go to the fucking north end.
Go write down what does that Hanover Street,
I don't remember the name of the street.
Begins with an h.
Go down that fucking street and uh,
you know,
find somebody,
looks really Italian from the old neighborhood and be like,
listen,
I don't want to eat on this street.
What's one,
a couple of blocks over that you go to?
I swear to God,
I won't tell anybody and it'll be the best fucking Italian that you can get in
the,
in Boston at least.
I think so.
Oh God.
That said,
that really made me feel fucking old.
Oh,
here's another is another one.
A black mass.
Hey Billy Bulger.
Nice.
Nice fucking call back.
They're not called BEC.
Nice reference there.
Billy Bulger,
he was the politician.
Did you see black mass?
He said,
I'm usually a pretty easy critic,
but it was pretty rough.
Nothing really happens.
And what does happen has been refuted by everyone who knows the story.
Well,
you can say that about every fucking movie.
I don't mean things like getting the color of his shirt right,
but major events and motives,
really disappointing.
While you know,
you can kind of say that about a Goodfellas,
the way you know [inaudible] were talking about that,
how they made Henry Hill look like Ray Liotta.
He says great looking movie star and then when you see him,
he was a little fucking worm.
Um,
so,
you know,
it is a movie.
I haven't seen it.
Um,
um,
I know some people liked it,
some people didn't,
but that I'm still gonna go see.
Cause I love Johnny Depp.
And also I remember when no country for old men came out and everybody's like,
Google the movie soaked.
And it ended up being like my favorite one ever.
So I did not see it.
And um,
I don't go to see movies to get a history lesson and I don't think he should.
I think you go there to be entertained.
Um,
I dunno.
It looks fucking great to me,
so I'm definitely gonna go it.
I think that's one of those
ones that everybody thought it was going to be a big shoot 'em up kind of thing.
And they did it in a little bit of a different way.
So they're like,
what the fuck?
And I'm calling it right now when it fucking goes on Netflix,
everyone be like,
you know what?
I actually liked it first.
He liked it,
you know,
so,
um,
I can't tell you this.
So that is a scary guy do that you did not want to fuck with.
That's all I knew when I was living in Massachusetts and fortunately I lived out
the safe suburbs and played street hockey in a cul de sac,
so I didn't have any sort of Southie,
goodwill hunting upbringing whatsoever.
Uh,
you know,
we just drove around and shit cars with the case of beer on the weekends,
drove around trying to find out the kids drive around and fucking with cases of
beer,
you know,
that's,
that's what you did.
That was the excitement in my town.
Um,
they need to know what we knew enough to stay away from heroin.
It's fucking killing me now.
Seeing all these kids on heroin after they get it on a painkillers,
it's unfucking believable,
man.
Unfucking believable that that has made a comeback and they get EEG.
You don't make a comeback from that fucking drug,
dude.
That's one of those drugs that,
and even when you get clean,
you know what I mean?
Every day you do,
you still want to fucking do it again.
I mean,
that's what a thing to do to yourself.
I don't think that that's worth it.
You know,
to put it to the biggest understatement ever.
Major fucking problem.
Enough to major.
It's a fucking problem.
Massachusetts problem in Vermont,
Maine,
all these places I'm going to,
they will like to kind of places you used to go to,
to get away from that shit.
Um,
it's out in the suburbs,
man.
It's a fucking epidemic.
Anyways.
All right,
wife thinks I'm nuts.
Hey Billy Davinci.
My wife thinks I'm losing my mind.
Well,
join the club a couple of weeks back.
I told her that I at the ripe age of 49 one to learn how to paint too.
That's fucking great.
Okay,
that's fucking,
dude,
this is the thing,
man.
If you want to stay excited in life and if you want to send off depression,
like this is a really depressing week for me,
man.
My uncle passed away and uh,
he's just the greatest guy ever.
And um,
cause that thing that,
you know,
no one,
I'm never going to see him again.
And then that other thing as far as like,
like that level of my relatives,
one of them passed away.
Like he's the first one and like,
um,
the next wave and you just start doing the math in your head and I'll quit the
last decade went by and it's like,
oh my God,
I'm going to fucking be that guy in like two months.
You feel so what's,
he can't stop the clock from ticking,
but you know,
nobody can stop you from enjoying yourself or having a good time and unless she
let them.
So,
um,
you know,
I think that's how I ended up,
I just,
I dunno,
I am a big fucking believer in learning how to do
shit and that whole a jack of all trades,
master of none.
Go Fuck Yourself.
I do stand up.
All right.
I do that thing.
I'm never going to master it because the second I think that I've mastered it,
I'm going to stop growing.
And then the depression comes back.
Like for me when I'm standing still and I got time to think and contemplate,
like however I'm wired,
it just,
it puts me in a fucking funk.
So I'm always chasing that next fucking carrot thing.
Like I'm learning how to smoke meat.
You know,
I was going to try to,
uh,
smoke some ribs this week,
but I got to go to the funeral.
I'm hoping,
you know,
I can maybe give that a shot this weekend.
But,
um,
you know,
playing drums,
I learned how to fly a helicopter.
Um,
I got into old cars and stuff and you know,
and I have like,
you know,
I don't have a tremendous amount of knowledge in any of that shit,
but our,
rather than obviously I got my pilot's license,
I had to know what the fuck goes.
Hey,
I kinda know how to do this.
Um,
I'll do it all.
By the way,
I'm doing a flight this week where,
uh,
I'm going to landed,
Elmonte.
Um,
and then I'm going to do a lap around the rose bowl,
which is so fucking cool.
I'm starting to like,
my big thing right now before I get instrument trained is I really want to get
comfortable on the radio and uh,
um,
into,
you know,
I already did the advanced autorotation class,
so I know I can get that thing to the ground at the fucking engine,
cuts out a,
which was the big thing for me.
So now I'm past that fear that I know if something bad happens,
I know I can get to the ground and I have fucking confidence in that.
So now my next little hurdle is I got to geek kid comfortable on the radio,
you know,
and know what to say and just get better at listening and looking for traffic
and all that type of shit.
And the only way to do it is to go fucking do it.
So
getting back to what you're talking about is you want to learn how to paint at
the ripe age of 49 like I just love even the way you're writing that,
I mean,
I don't want to put words into your mouth,
but the,
the tone underneath that is that you shouldn't be trying new things or learning
new things at 49 you should be set in your ways.
You should have your fucking routine.
And for some people that is comforting.
But uh,
to fuck that,
if you want to learn how to paint,
I don't give a fuck if you're 89 the keep your mind active as supposed to sit in
their rotten in between your ears.
So anyways,
he said,
you know,
I'm ripe old age of 49 and then I let her know that I want wanting to paint.
She immediately changed the subject to shed a that Oh,
she immediately change the subject to to the shed.
Okay.
That needs cleaning out.
I explained to her that one has nothing to do with the other.
I can clean the shed and learn how to play paint.
I'm self employed.
I brought it up again and she rolled her eyes.
I love my wife,
but this has me wondering,
uh,
what are the things that she shot down in the past that maybe I just accepted a,
you talk about,
you talked about that in your last specialists.
Especially,
what's my move here?
I don't want to pass over this.
I'd rather address it and fix it.
Uh,
what's your next move?
I had to go down to the art supply store and get yourself a fucking easel and
some paints and I would learn how to paint.
This is okay.
This is the deal,
dude.
She has no fucking argument here.
This is like literally you want to learn to do something that's going to make
your life more enjoyable.
Um,
and that's what I would say.
I would just say,
listen,
I want to learn something that's going to uh,
make my life more enjoyable and fill me with happiness and it doesn't involve me
a fucking another woman.
So what exactly is she a problem?
Lay Right.
What is your problem?
If you want to address it,
like,
dude,
you're going to destroy in this.
Just sit down and just say,
listen,
I need to talk to you about something.
All right.
And immediately she's going to be off guard cause she didn't cause you know,
there's going to be a talk and you've had a time to fucking get your ideas in
order to just say,
listen.
Um,
the other day when I mentioned to you that I wanted to learn how to paint,
you immediately said that the shed needed to be cleaned out.
When I told you that I had enough time to do both,
you rolled your eyes at me and uh,
don't say it the way I just said,
you rolled your eyes.
See,
I get the anger.
You,
Gabby,
you rolled your eyes,
you go back,
you bring your head back so you're not getting in a grill so she can actually
hear you and she won't be on the defensive.
Just feels like you rolled your eyes at me and um,
that hurt my feelings because if there was something that you ever wanted to do
that was going to make you happy,
I would never
come at you in a negative way.
I would encourage you to do it.
So I was just wondering what was behind that
and uh,
you know,
just let her talk and talk your way through and just say,
listen,
like for the rest of my life,
I'm going to be trying new things because it makes my life enjoyable and it
would crush me that the woman that I love,
which somehow get in the way of that.
All right,
the shed is going to be cleaned out and I'm learning how to paint.
All right?
And I don't want to paint a picture of you being a con to me,
so why don't you lighten up their sugar tits.
See right there.
See what happens always in the end.
I get mean.
That's why I couldn't talk to that guy in the fucking a cigar bar.
Um,
all right.
All right.
Okay.
Bill,
aren't you paranoid?
Hey Billy B a,
aren't you a bit paranoid with all this tracking and surveillance?
Uh,
I think he's talking about the microchipping and all that shit.
He said,
I noticed that this is a typical American psyche of Jesus Christ here in Europe.
We are a bit,
well,
a lot more relaxed about those things.
Um,
I don't
know if people are doing this just to try to get me all fucking fucked up,
but I noticed that about people from other countries like they are so fucking
arrogant with like,
they think they know all the American psyche.
Like what do you know about the American psyche?
You don't fucking live here.
What the shit you watching the BBC,
you fucking dope over in America,
we're a little more relaxed.
Really based on what?
Based on what.
Isn't that where the last two world wars started?
Oh,
what are you go way back to then look at how can one would fucking Russia pulled
out all those kinds of Bosnian Serbs,
Russia,
they get,
you're not more relaxed.
Okay.
You're not any more fucking relaxed fucking maniac.
She can't even go to a football game without beating the shit out of each other.
Getting all fucking hammered.
You're not more relaxed.
All right.
I don't see that at all.
I'm not saying we're better than you or what,
like you know,
and also you're not a bit more paranoid.
I love how Scotland Shutdown Monsanto when they wanted to have their fucking
genetically altered food coming to their country and they're like,
you're not fucking doing that.
I don't think you're more relaxed.
I don't think Greece looks at fucking relaxed right now.
Is they got in bed with the evil fucking bankers are now.
I don't know what the fuck happened over there.
Their whole fucking economy collapsed.
I don't see many relaxed things over there.
Yeah.
Nice and relaxed.
You draw cartoon and then somebody comes in and sprays the place with bullets.
I add so fucking chill.
God,
it's so refined in relaxed over there.
Fucking neo Nazis.
Can you go to a fucking football game without being reminded a Hitler?
Jesus fucking Christ.
What could you got a king and queen riding around in a carriage.
You think it's all fucking chill.
Um,
anyways.
Okay.
My question here is why I see that you will reject anything that makes your life
easier and more convenient.
Um,
well that all depends on how you,
uh,
define convenient,
which you spelled incorrectly.
He goes,
but it's collecting any data,
whether it's purchasing habits,
location and such.
I prefer to see personalized ads rather than random ads for moms.
If I buy something all the time in a market,
why not create clubcard?
You will pay less.
Oh my God.
What a dope.
It doesn't matter that you will receive an email every once in a while,
which will land in spam anyways.
Dude,
you're not paying less.
Okay.
Do you want to say it?
You're not paying less.
Do you know anything about corporations?
Okay,
they're never going to make less money.
They're going to create this whole thing like,
Hey,
join the club man and look,
you'll get 40% off this shit that we can't fucking sell.
That's what they give you a discount on.
And then if they actually got some PR,
whatever their prime rib is that they're selling you,
all they do is Jack up the price.
Go,
hey,
it used to be this and now it's this.
So you,
you give the them the perception that you're getting a lower price and I don't
have,
I'm not paranoid dude.
I am informed,
believe it or not,
and I always call myself a fucking dope.
All right?
Cause I know that I am and I don't think that I know everything,
but,
um,
I do understand how corporations operate.
Okay.
And they literally sit there and they go dead babies or more money for us.
And they actually debate going like,
well,
how much will the parents suing us for their dead babies costs us to settle out
of court versus how much money you know,
to have these led and fuse fucking pacifiers.
And if the pacifiers,
I mean,
using this obviously is a fuck.
I know you're rolling your eyes because you fucking think you know everything,
which is certainly do as just shitting on my country.
A country you don't even fucking live in.
Um,
they will choose the fucking,
the product.
Auto companies did that.
Yeah.
You know,
whether they knew like fucking police,
like to what the Crown Victoria,
when they knew cops were getting rear-ended when they are on the road and we're
burning to death,
they fucking squelched all of that fucking information and they took the fucking
lawsuit.
All right?
They're not on your side.
They're not trying to make your life any easier.
What they're trying to do is they're gay.
They're,
they're,
they're invading your fucking privacy.
Like,
look,
dude,
I don't have a problem that you don't have a problem with somebody invading your
privacy.
Okay.
But she should have to give consent to that.
And what I don't like is I have not given my consent.
Okay.
I didn't give my consent for you to put my fucking bank account information
online.
They just fucking did it.
I don't want to bank online and they just put it up there anyways.
Then I had to go down to the fucking bank and go through this whole fucking maze
and they were very hostile before they would let me take my own banking
information off of the fucking Internet that they exposed my entire fucking
adult life of working to getting hacked into.
They exposed all of that.
They made the choice and not me.
I think that that's fucked up.
And if you think like when you go through history,
how human beings have handled any level of power,
I'm talking about the average person just getting their own fucking Sitcom.
What that does to their fucking psyche.
Okay.
When you're trying to take over shit,
the thought of rebellion and all that is always in the back of your head.
If you fucking microchip everybody and you know where everybody is,
you could fucking just an,
and you put all the money is then on the microchip and all your shit is just on
that.
All you gotta do is just shut somebody chip off and you've killed any sort of
rebuttal to anything that you're doing.
That's it.
And the future,
when you go to a protest,
they'll just fucking,
they'll just have,
they'll have some sort of satellite,
everybody's chip number will show up and they'll just be shut it off and they'll
starve you for fucking 10 days.
So you'll learn the fucking lesson.
They won't kill you.
Cause if they kill you,
that'll,
that'll cause more people to get upset.
But just sort of kick it back and the people like,
yeah,
you know what?
I'd love to go to a fucking protest.
You know?
Right now it's like,
I'd love to go to a protest,
but the cops are gonna beat the Shit on me,
which is so fucking ridiculous.
Okay,
you can't go to a protest.
There is no protest.
So you go to a protest and the cops beat the shit out of you.
That's basically what happens.
And then they always try to act like,
oh,
well these guys got out of line.
Give me a fucking break.
They'd been doing that since the fucking beginning.
Um,
so I don't think I'm paranoid,
sir.
If you want all of your fucking information and all that out there to make your
life more convenient and you don't have to think,
you have to think less.
Like I don't,
I don't think that's good.
I don't think that happened like that fucking app on my phone.
This is my own personal thing and I'm not going to shit on your fucking country.
I only shit on after you shit on my country.
All right.
Okay.
I don't think there's anything wrong with your continent or your country and I
don't think there's anything fucking wrong with the fact that you don't give a
shit about this.
So you think it makes your life easy.
That's fine.
All right.
Okay.
But I mean,
I,
I'm not,
I don't want to be microchipped dude.
I don't,
I also find that on my phone,
the little gps thing that fucking tell him,
make a left and blah,
blah,
blah.
I've never had more fucking problems getting to when I had the map and I had to
use my brain,
I was made way more effective.
Okay.
Way more effective.
I start fucking looking at the picture.
They'll go make a right.
And then there's like a lazy right and a right.
And I'm looking at it and I can't,
you know,
ash,
I'm fucking driving.
It makes me more dangerous.
A driver.
I don't,
I dunno.
I like using my fucking brain.
I'll figure out my own shit.
Um,
and I don't think that this stuff makes my life easier because it's constantly
has to be updated and replaced.
And then you replace it and then you throw it in the fucking ocean and you're
polluting the environment that you're in.
You know?
And I know a guy like you is probably rolling your fucking eyes right now
because all you give a fuck about is your little flat or whatever the fuck you
live.
And having them,
oh yeah.
I like soft t shirts all.
Thank you for that ad right there that I can click on.
Like if that's how you want to live your life.
God bless you.
But uh,
I don't think I'm being paranoid at all.
You know what I mean?
Anyways,
he said,
I'd love to see in Poland,
maybe the next time you were in Europe.
Uh,
I would love to go to Poland.
I actually heard that a up along the coast is beautiful and actually a south of
Poland is great places to take vacation.
Who fucking knew?
I didn't know that till I went over there.
So my apologies to any other part of Europe.
I didn't,
I just so sick of people like,
uh,
not seeing how fucked up their places and just constantly,
you know,
I want to tell him I was flying across the country.
There was this chick from Australia.
Okay.
We're literally in the United States flying from one us city to another and she
shitting on the u s to me,
a US citizen.
Not saying we don't have our faults.
Absolutely.
Apps the fucking loopy.
You know what I mean?
I don't know what the fuck we're doing.
We want a world war in four and a half years.
We've spent 15 fucking years,
14 years over in fucking Iraq.
I don't know what we're doing.
Okay.
Trying to put up Starbucks.
MMM.
Anyways,
I'm not saying we don't have our fucking faults,
but I mean just this is just a common level of decency.
You know what I mean?
I to sit there and go to another country and shit on the country to somebody
from that country and then say what country you're from it,
I don't know.
I,
this is Dell.
There's a fucking level of ignorance there that,
uh,
I just feel like Americans are always getting accused of and not everybody
else's patting themselves on the back about how fucking amazing their country is
because it's not the u s and I'm just saying,
you know,
you guys got your fucking warts too.
All right.
Okay.
So fucking relax.
I like going to your countries.
I like meeting the people over there and I know I tease you and make fun of your
sports of Blahblahblahblahblah.
I know I compared to Sydney,
Australia to Sacramento,
California.
But you know,
being,
you know,
just busting your fucking boss.
Maybe I'm being overly sensitive.
Maybe I'm the cutting this.
I have no idea.
Yeah.
All I know is uh,
I got to get on with my fucking day here because uh,
obviously,
uh,
I get the bullshit I have to deal with,
you know,
fucking annoyed the shit out of me.
I got to say this really fucking quickly cause I don't think it's going to get a
laugh from the comedy club.
Cause when I was watching CNN and that fucking horrific shooting at the school
happened and his fucking lady,
all right,
she looks like Mary Lou Retton is flipping out because she can't get the right
number of dead people at the school.
It's like,
isn't it enough that it's a fucking tragedy?
What are you flipping like the sheriffs on faith?
Let's fucking nine people or 10 people.
It's like lady fucking relax.
The tragedy happened.
The tragedy is going to exist tomorrow.
All right?
Maybe law enforcement is trying to figure out who fucking did it.
Why and all of that shit.
Stop acting like you solve in the fucking case.
You're freaking out because you want to get the right amount of dead people so
you have the accurate shit.
So people will go to you and there's a fucking tragedy so you could sell,
get,
make more money.
When you sell your fucking fruit loops,
you fucking right.
Yeah.
Can't,
oh fuck.
It annoyed me.
She sitting there screaming and yelling and just a sweetheart,
just go to bed.
All right.
Just go to bed.
I don't need to see.
And I,
and I don't understand people who sit there and they watched that shit and then
they show the pictures of,
of the,
uh,
the relatives and the friends crying,
hugging,
and all that.
I,
every time I saw it,
I would turn the fucking channel.
I don't want to see what the guy looked like who did it.
I don't want to know his fucking name.
Fuck that piece of shit.
I don't know if he's alive or dead.
If you know,
if he's alive,
uh,
they should kill him.
They should be out.
This is the guy.
This is the guy who did it without a doubt.
We know this.
Okay.
And you just take a right out in the fucking street to behind the year.
That's it.
Over.
I think they should do that with all sex offenders,
all pedophiles,
all of that.
You can't cure those people.
Just take them right out to buying a fucking
ear.
All right,
drag them off,
throw them in a pit,
bulldoze over him,
and then,
uh,
I dunno,
fucking turn the music on.
All right.
That's the podcast for this week.
Everybody.
When it got a little sideways there at the end,
got a little sad.
I look,
obviously I'm a little fucking paranoid.
I'll give you that,
but I think it's a healthy fucking paranoia.
You don't even read,
you know,
when you're watching cigarette companies going like,
I don't think cigarettes so raw.
I don't think they're addictive at all.
Ignoring all of their fucking information.
Right?
Government spraying agent orange over its own fucking troops,
ignoring it,
denying it.
Right.
What's the latest one?
Oh,
that fracking.
It fucking absolutely destroys the drinking water and then those corporation
guys sit there going like,
I would drink that drinking water.
Well,
here's some,
would you like to drink it?
No,
I don't think I'm fucking paranoid.
I don't want those types of people to go around having more information on the
public because there are absolute fucking psychopaths.
Dude,
the head of Nestle doesn't think water is a basic human right.
He wants to,
he wants to own the rain.
These people are out of their fucking minds and the president only makes four
and a grant of fucking year in needs.
That guy's money,
so they're not going to talk about those guys.
Oh,
but God forbid,
God forbid you make fun of Caitlyn Jenner and a fucking strip mall.
You're going to make the fucking national notes.
Oh,
I'm on my soapbox.
Go Fuck Yourself.
You can't sell.
Talk to you on Thursday.
Okay.